very busy July has come to an end we
have a pact August ahead of us although
it's more packed in the beginning than
in the end as well soon see so it's time
for me to do another dr. Sadler update
video where I talk about what went on
during July and what we've got coming up
in august as usual I'm going to begin
this by highlighting three things that I
particularly want to bring to your
attention if you're a follower of my
channel or of me on Google+ or Twitter
or Facebook any of the other social
media things where you might see me so
one big thing is we've reached a sort of
milestone in the half of our hagel
project not a milestone with the Patrian
pledging thing although that would be
cool as well if it happened this month
but a milestone in terms of where we're
going with it we are just finishing up
with the consciousness section that the
first real section of the phenomenology
and we're moving into self consciousness
where you're going to find the stuff
everybody likes to talk about like the
master-slave dialectic and so I'm going
to be doing some stuff this month to
call attention to the half hour Hagel
project and perhaps get some of you to
consider whether you want to become
supporters backers patrians of the
project so another thing that's that's
quite interesting that I'm very happy
about is I'm teaching my second class
for the global Center for Advanced
Studies where I'm not only a professor
but also an administrator this is a
summer class 11 month on Plato's
symposium it started on the first of
August and is going to continue until
the end of august there's still time if
you're interested in it during the first
week to enroll before we start getting
really deep into the material so if
you're interested in that you can look
at the the description of this video and
i'll put a link to it if you want to
sign up for it there's still time unless
you're watching this much later in the
month the third thing is that as
I brought up in my previous update video
we are in the process of relocating from
where we currently are in the Hudson
Valley of New York about an hour and a
half north of the city in the City of
Kingston to Wisconsin southeastern
Wisconsin where reason ior our business
and our activities are going to be based
Wisconsin is the the home state of
myself and my wife who actually I'd met
in high school so we're really looking
forward to going home and were you know
it's going to take us a bit of planning
and staging in order to do that
particularly because we've got so many
books so we're doing the move in stages
and it's already beginning in August we
are we've already got things packed up
we're planning on moving some of the
stuff out there we're not going to be
completely gone from this area until
October but I just wanted to put it on
people's radar so let's talk about the
month of July extremely busy month for
for me and probably for a lot of other
people as well i'm guessing i had for
public appearances the first one was in
the global center for advanced studies
reading roof this is an online thing I
gave a guest lecture they are reading
Hegel's phenomenology so I get a guest
lecture on the parts of
self-consciousness that people don't
usually get to because they just read
the master-slave dialectic I looked at
stoicism skepticism and the unhappy
consciousness that went quite well I was
very happy with it I also did another
understanding anger lecture in that
series that I've been doing at the
kingston public library this time it was
on Plutarch and particularly on his text
on a controlling anger but but also
looking at how anger plays itself out in
his other works as well we had a great
discussion the video for that is is
linked to so if you're interested in
watching that you can see that you can
also see all the other understanding
anger
videos as well now i also got asked by
the partially examined life which i
think some of you probably know is a
podcasting show they also the blog the
really a whole community of people who
are are doing philosophy in a rather
public way they asked me if I would come
on to their after show which is a google
hangout on air as a Content expert on
niches birth of tragedy which they've
done a show on actually three shows on
and so I said I said yes and we went on
for about two hours or so I had a great
time talking with the people they're
actually looking forward to connecting
up with some of the people once we're
back in Wisconsin since I think
partially examined life may in fact be
based in in Wisconsin towards the end of
the month I went to the reading an some
conference in Boston hosted by Boston
College and under the aegis of the IaaS
which is the international association
for an some studies I think it's called
this is sort of an umbrella organization
for for worldwide organizations that are
involved in the study of Anselm of
Canterbury and all the other things that
he's connected with and you know 12th
century politics thought history just
wonderful stuff this was one of the best
conferences I've been to in a long time
I did not hear a single paper where I
thought this you know this isn't very
good everything was high caliber the
people who were there some of them were
old friends some of the more people that
I had met over a decade ago who I
reconnected with who are very interested
in insane handsome I even had the time
to meet with a couple of YouTube
supporters in town because I said look
I'm going to be in boston and i was able
to meet with a good friend of mine
Christian DuPont who's now working over
in the library of boston college and
he's a very important scholar in the
history of phenomenology among many
other things it was cool to be able to
connect up with
I gave a paper on Anselm's prayers and
the topic of justice and mercy within
them something like I'm doing a book
project on and I've been doing a few
things here and there dealing with that
so this is a chance to start you know
moving that research forward paper was
very well received gave a lot of good
feedback on other people's paper so it
was a really wonderful experience I also
on a personal note had had my i went to
the annual lemco family reunion out in
illinois good drive from here for myself
and the kids but well worth it it goes
on every year I come from a very large
and and you know pretty well close and
connected family where we've done this
tradition going back decades we get
together for about three days and just
hang out have a good time with each
other so now going back to professional
activities in the youtube channel I I
paired back my my activities to doing
about three to four videos a week
probably going to stick with something
close to that this month coming up so
that meant I got half hour Hagel videos
done not quite so many as I had hoped to
but you know at least I got 45 in this
month I'm shooting for six but I didn't
get in quite make that at least a few
more critical thinking videos based on
their focused on fallacies and I
continued releasing the core concept
epicurious videos that I had originally
shot for my ethics class that's that's
ongoing right now but which I've
released for the general public and
those have been getting a lot of
traction you know we did something
different with having you know much
nicer thumbnails and I think we're
probably going to do that for the rest
of the core concept videos once we get
to it been working out a few writing
projects I did get some blogging done
merrily in half hour Hagel and the heavy
metal philosopher blogs I'd hope to get
two more but you know and very very busy
time I've been doing quite a bit more
academic writing including getting my
paper ready for the conference but also
a few other academic writing projects as
well did some work with philosophical
counseling some consulting work and a
lot of behind-the-scenes work with the
global Center for Advanced Studies they
had a very important conference in
Athens democracy rising a huge success
which is great because now what what I'm
more involved in is getting the fall
classes ready for the global Center for
Advanced Studies in general but but for
me for the Institute of humanities and
Social Sciences that I'm supposed to be
in charge of so I've been doing a lot of
back and forth working with the people
in the G cast you know trying to get
things ready a bit more about that later
I think so what else I've been prepping
the symposium class which just got
started I mentioned at the beginning and
continuing to teach my online marys
summer 10-week ethics class so that's
that's July let's talk now about Oh
August what do we got coming up in
august so it's it's a it's pretty packed
in the beginning of the month as far as
advance and then I've got some some
downtime or at least what looks on the
calendar like down time this week I'm
doing another global Center for Advanced
Studies Hagel summer reading group guest
lecture it'll be on the religion section
I won't be going through the entire
religion section just natural religion
and art religion probably not going into
revealed religion that will be august
six which is thursday at 10pm if you're
interested in getting involved into that
in
and you know being part of that group
you want to contact this guy skipper
boat right you can find him in the event
listing and he can get you squared away
that weekend following actually just
coming up really soon well I guess
eighth we've got understanding anger
lecture eight the penultimate lecture in
the series and this will be focused on
early Christian understandings of anger
so I'm not just looking at one thinker
I'm looking at a bunch of thinkers
ranging from John Cassian to to
Augustine to chrysostom I'm going to do
a little digging in Jerome to see what
he might have to say because he was a
pretty angry guy a lot of time and a few
other people like locked on CS you know
talking about divine anger but we're
going to be looking at a lot of this
stuff and I'm going to focus in
particular on which scriptural passages
ended up being these you know places
where these guys would focus like the
you know don't get angry with your
brother stuff from the Sermon on the
Mount which they read in very different
ways so that's going to be very fun
lecture if you're interested in that if
you're in the area 1030 saturday august
eighth at the kingston public library
almost immediately after that the next
day i'm giving a guest sermon at the
unitarian universalist community the
Catskills here in Kingston again that in
that case the lecture is going to be a
little bit different it's going to be on
rainer maria rilke and his conception of
solitude and how they can be useful for
us it's actually called solitude slowing
down and clearing space that will be
sunday the ninth at ten-thirty so we've
got a few other things going on as well
a lot of video work that i'll be doing
i'm going to try to get as many
half-hour Hagel videos done this month
as i can so i'm hoping to get at least
six done and like I mentioned at the the
beginning we're passing an important
milestone we're making the transition
from this difficult force in the
understanding section and consciousness
in general to self consciousness where
you're going to find
you know people engaged with each other
the master-slave dialectic the battle to
the death all this very sexy material
and then stoicism skepticism and the
unhappy consciousness so we're going to
begin that we're not going to actually
finish up with all that material this
month but we're going to begin delving
into that I'm doing a lot of core
concept videos for the symposium class I
haven't done any core accounts of videos
on Plato's symposium although I've done
them on a lot of other works so I'm
remedying that with an entire sequence
that I'll be using for my students but
i'll also be releasing to the general
public to help them out if they're
reading that text i'm going to try to
get some more critical thinking fallacy
videos done i've been meaning to get
that channel filled out and up and
running hopefully before classes begin
in the fall so that students have that
as a resource got a lot of writing
projects going on mostly academic
writing although i'm going to be doing a
bit more blogging this month i'm working
on polishing up several and some papers
including the one that i presented just
at this recent conference like I said on
an Psalms prayers and how mercy and
justice play out in those but I've got a
number of other ants on papers that I've
just had sitting that I should have sent
out to journals some time ago but now
need to be finely polished up and then
sent out to be considered for
publication need to you know I probably
got about 10 of them actually on my hard
drive sitting there that I just haven't
done you know the final steps with so I
won't get to all ten this month but I
need to delve into that I'm working on
some papers still on Gabriel Marcel I
began a paper on Marcel's role in the
Christian philosophy debates earlier
this summer and then they had to you
know put it on hold I'm going to finish
that up this this month I'm also going
to be working on another paper for a
conference that is coming up in the fall
where I will be presenting on Gabrielle
Marcel and jean-paul Sartre as
existentialist who represent extremely
different views on the existential and
who actually had a
personal beef with each other quite a
bit of the time I've been I've been
asked to write a fairly popularly
oriented book discussing anger from a
variety of philosophical and Theological
perspectives and so I'm working on the
chapter outline and the prospectus for
that this month I already have a
publisher lined up who's interested in
me writing a book on that so I need to
get cracking on that material it's a
good opportunity for me to think out
exactly how I want to approach matters
who I want to be in the book who I don't
want to be in the book because you know
it's kind of like triage you know same
thing when you're when you're teaching a
class you know who is going to make it
into the syllabus and the reading list
and who isn't same thing when you're
writing a book because it books can only
be so long um coursework I am finishing
up a marist 10-week online summer ethics
course and I'm prepping for two courses
in the fall that i'll be teaching with
mayors world views and values you may
have seen some of the videos for that
there's an entire course out there in
which I go through 10 weeks of that 10
different thinkers I'm also teaching the
symposium class right now and at this
time if you're watching this video if
you still want to sign up for that class
there's still time to enroll with the
global Center for Advanced Studies but
I'm also getting the global Center for
Advanced Studies fall classes ready in
the Institute for humanities and Social
Sciences we actually have four classes
coming up one of which will be taught by
many philosophical foundations core
class in the GES another core class is
going to be ethics moral theories and
applications but we are going to also
have two other elective classes a
philosophical approaches to religion and
a social and political philosophy class
so we've got four different instructors
I've recruited them I'm you know we're
finishing up the bits and bolts of
putting together the course sites
getting the syllabus syllabi completely
you know airtight
you know developing rubrics for
assignments all the stuff that goes into
having an entire curriculum and this is
the core this is the beginning this is
the the kernel for something that's
going to expand into something larger
and larger over time the Institute for
humanities and Social Sciences in the
gps is going to grow over the next
several years we're building a
philosophy program and so I'm really
excited to be involved in the start of
that I will be shooting a video a little
bit later this month and releasing it
where I'm going to talk in considerable
detail about each of these classes and
why it could be a good idea for
interested students lifelong learners
professionals to take these global
Center for Advanced Studies classes so
that is pretty much it for the month of
August now that I think about it that's
an awful lot of stuff to try to get done
so I should probably bring this to a
close and wish you a good month ahead